[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from nine nations converge in
st. Louis as us chess champs calm
presents the second annual summer chess
classic hello and welcome to the final
day of the summer chess classic during
2019
as always we're your hosts my name is
Caleb Denby I'm joined by the wonderful
Grandmaster Jessie cry and a lot of the
action has already been decided here
today Jessie we got a little bit of a
late start thanks to all that exciting
action happening in Croatia and so let's
actually just take a look and see where
we stand right now at this very moment
in the a group the tournament has been
decided Lee Anne Lee is your 2019 a
group champion of the summer chess
classic Jeffrey Zhang tried his best to
get a full point today if he had we
would be sitting here waiting for
playoffs but he only managed to draw and
so Liam Lee is our sole victor here in
2019 in the B group this tournament was
actually decided yesterday with Grigory
Oprah and being our champion we got a
chance to talk to him a little bit
yesterday and I think he stayed for
quite a while giving us his thoughts on
a few of the remaining games and so
congratulations to Grigory once again
for taking home the gold
in the B group Egor Kovalenko and
Havana's kuboos Ian after their scores
today are tying for second place and
lastly in the C group the story of one
man stayed the story of one man
throughout almost this entire event our
tears and Ike's sons took the lead
pretty early on and around I think four
or five and he has kept it ever since
finishing with a astonishing six and a
half out of ten a wonderful score
following him is a romper Cobian with a
full point in this round bumping him up
to six Dmitry Gordievsky it has a chance
to actually also catch around huh Cobian
and tie for that second place spot but
you know the championships all decided
here Jesse
oh you're a little bit too late to catch
that action happening live here we see
the tournament hall the remaining player
is walking around a lot of the players
already having vacated maybe four four
four good hopefully they'll come back
for more tournaments later but this
tournament is is wrapping up let's take
a look and see what kinds of prize money
these players are winning for their
scores here in the event in the a group
Liam Leigh is taking home $12,000 for
his first-place prize and Geoffrey Zhang
is going home with a cool $9,000 not a
bad week of chess for pretty much
everybody in the a group and over in the
B group McGorry oberon takes home the
first-place prize of $6,000 and like I
said a second place is still kind of up
for grabs we might see a tie there
depending on Dmitri gordievsky's I'm
sorry not to meet you're Gordievsky
depending on no Daniel Friedman's finish
we might see something happen in the B
group there for second place and lastly
in the C group the first-place prize a
$4,000 goes to mr. archers nikons for
his wonderful like I said six and a half
out of ten score a crazy high score for
one of these events well done to him as
always you can join us for this
broadcast on YouTube at st. Louis chess
club you can join us on us chess champs
calm if you want to see how these games
took place and you want to follow along
with the game still in remaining and you
can join us on Twitter using the hashtag
summer chess classic well Jessie with
the winners decided I think we should
just try and get them in here for an
interview as quickly as we can we're
gonna do so interviews today talk about
the tournament kind of recap the whole
thing and then it's fiesta it's party
time people are done 10 rounds they're
exhausted they want to hang out and tell
some rude jokes that's what we do
alright just a fun way to wrap up wrap
up this event I think that's right so
why don't we take a look at
a couple games well late for our tours
to get down to the studio well alright
let's start out with this ganguly game
and if he so we're thinking that if
Ganguly can somehow win he would what
tie first he would be in second place if
genius
oh if either player wins then they tie
for second place so the only result that
doesn't put any either player in a tie
is a draw
no but Friedman can't win anything right
so it's just Ganguly so no free if
Freeman well yeah so Ganguly has the
advantage obviously I'm sorry I sounds
like archers is ready to come in so I'm
gonna step out now and let him get in
the studio here great and while that's
going on I will say this game definitely
Ganguly was pressing for the longest
time and now I just want to say I'm not
sure what's happening anymore the the
the bishop and King are active and
basically it was one of these situations
where in order to hold on or try to hold
on to his extra pawn black became
passive and I'll just show that moment
over here where let's see we got this
position and black became passive here
so we're going to talk about this though
with our guest
after our interview we'll have him help
us understand some of these positions
that were going through there to help
decide the tournament and we have with
us our tours nake sons and he won the
tournament very good and you know I was
just telling Mart or as I said hey so
the guy who wins the see he gets to play
in the B group next year and they said
it's not totally official but that's the
unofficial understanding you know so
hopefully we can see you back next year
in the B group and yeah how does this
change your life oh I don't know I mean
this this is my first visit in United
States doing a chest door uh-huh and
before the san luis i played in the
national open vegas sure the second
place they're gonna be the eager Colin
Cowie
here oh yeah I mean I'm very excited
yesterday I had a very funny game I'm
sorry for my fans cover following me
true for me I I got gifted the game in
one move and I was so surprised that it
happened and I just could not pull
myself together and I managed to blunder
away another win so for me the most
critical thing was to gather myself
together because it was quite difficult
to be honest I mean after after
yesterday's terrible game and that was a
bit yeah embarrassing to say the least
but I had to pull myself together and I
think I did it quite nicely today well
we were shocked too I mean we had
grigory Oprah new one the B section and
we had him in here looking at your game
and we started right when your opponent
played for okay for we've already have
to be played okay for and all of a
sudden we were like wait a second I have
to look at for it to draw it's
unbelievable as a big shock I mean what
is going on there but of course I missed
a few easy wins before but I mean this
happens I mean yeah I was tired it was a
long tournament so and even after okay
for I liked what you did you played
route that roof g8 move had a lot of
venom we were uncertain for took us a
long time to actually see that it was a
draw you probably probably for you guys
too it was not totally clear it felt for
me if there's a draw but the most
critical moment was that I realized I
have to play in that position room g5
earlier so that I don't miss this idea
King before King g3 King edge 4 and I
might even lose this end game so I also
need to be careful yeah
and so now what are you what are you
playing next I'm going comedy God
tomorrow and we initially were planning
also to play in the World Open but we
changed those plans because I have
another tournament I'm gonna play in
France in San Quentin for my clubs for
my club an open tournament in memoriam
of followers clinics who passed away
last year
and yeah it's very important tournament
also for me and
so but anyway I mean if I'm gonna be
invited here another year let's say next
year yeah be groups fantastic I mean I
have a gladly come yeah well why don't
we get your opinion on some of these
games um I guess this is the first one I
want to ask you about with Friedman
against Ganguly you know before I even
show this position this might be a
little reminiscent of your game
yesterday because it looked like white
was or rather black had this very at
least he was he was better in this
position right white is just kind of
suffering passively and here so he's up
upon he plays might be a you know and so
it's a little passive but he's you know
he's doing one of these things where
you're trying to make yourself you're
trying to force a win I mean Ganguly
obviously did not want to draw so he
first looking for ways to continue this
game and I think Daniel would be happy
to make a draw huh but summer he miss
played it yeah this is the last moment
when I saw the game and now it's now
it's a little little dangerous looking
right probably I'm not sure what exactly
he missed what did he play in that um he
maybe he was planning to play 97 and he
missed this should be 8 maybe that is
the that's the point at least from a
farmer and I was looking at this
position I thought if if I was here that
black I would play 97 the room g6 and
activate my be system so I would imagine
there was some sort of fun blunder in
the calculations maybe I'm wrong well
and this is also the last move time
control so that's it you know it's very
understandable one nice trick here I
thought was busy before here and now
there's no rookie rookie 3 because of
king f4 and rook f8 yeah so you probably
might have missed that one too so we
have here 97 check a5
so now obviously black is fighting for
the draw Bishop is too powerful
I don't know what to make of this it
looks lost but it's still very
complicated right
oh well it's difficult to tell oh well
now it's black come over right it's
black - yeah how about we just take on
a3 a problem later okay trees the seems
to be the practical choice okay three
king of five I would imagine and the
threat is rook h7 soccer checkmate ideas
yeah
fool this is Rafa probably still black
should be okay let's I need to activate
no rooks on column not sure how because
rook h7 King get King g6 a bit dangerous
e3 maybe okay - so the King g6 can
always be met by some rookie to check so
Luke h5 there's some sort of a race of
pawns
it should be okay some night of fate you
can even play at some moment to form two
points versus two points at each side
okay just to show what our tours idea is
the rook h7 King e8 I cannot play King
ISA easily there's even a for gonna play
right and night f8 you know so there's
maybe more than one way for black to do
this but let's uh okay so we're gonna
have a race you're a little faster but I
did get here with check let's just try
but I mean if if I'm playing like I can
just play Knight of fate right there's
no check on h7 I keep the g6 square so
something like let's try to g5 something
like Guruji to make sense so my dirty
trick was that one this is so clear rook
h6 B 3 a 4 I've got the feeling that
this will end of it's some kind of
Perpetual checksum or maybe maybe I'm
wrong I mean instead of this if white
why does not want this if you go a few
moves back when he played g5 he could
have just leave a lot of checks h 7h h 7
i checked right let's look at the game
in the game black played b4 and just
said let's run save ourselves a little
time let's I might stop the pond yeah
you can put the rook on the B be ranking
e5 eventually try to capture those both
alright maybe not immediately even the
pawn is not going anywhere
I just wanted to set up your rook 8:7
King e6 thing I thought that was a good
idea yeah but it's not threatening right
because of 99 f8 that's so it's a black
place QB tree so you need to activate
you hook some call I wrote these six
maybe I'll rube these six so king king
b7 on something like maybe he checked in
the game he checked immediately on h7
well it makes sense because what is the
idea after king
six-six and so it was played maybe just
win some time ago page six you can
always go back through but fact that's
what happened no risk a choice I'm not
sure what was wrong with okay three but
let's say I could even play here
something like a rook rook c6 for
example so I want to put the rook on b7
yeah so let's say you played v3 rook c7
King g6 the room b7 that is the idea so
looks sort of risky for black because I
mean he just gave up that 8.4 I'm not
sure for what and the pole on a five
phase maybe even irrelevant because why
just wants to take some take on age five
followed by h4 Kingi 6-5 well they
agreed to draw they just went back and
forth
all right Arcturus thank you so much for
coming in and congratulations I hope to
see you back next year hopefully and
then you'll play national open you'll
come here and then world open to I'm not
sure I'm gonna playing the national open
anymore but I definitely look forward
for San Luis well it was a fantastic
experience here alright congratulations
again
and so while we're waiting for LEM to
come in who I think is gonna come in for
an interview we will take a quick look
at the other game which is finishing
which is El Shawn against Demetri
Gordievsky earlier on I felt this
position was winning just on an
intuitive level and I guess I still feel
that way the general principle is just
usually caleb is fighting with me a
little bit on this one but usually is
that the it'll be a win if you if it
were to be a one King and pawn endgame
if you lifted the Knights and the reason
that's a nice rule of thumb is these end
games with the Knights are actually so
complicated that it's nice to have
some way of trying at least to evaluate
it without getting bogged down and like
a thousand variations yeah this seems
like a position where it might be true
right but I'm just a little a little
cynical at having watched some of these
Croatia games like especially mangas
this game against fishy when the she
found some miracle draw in the night end
game these things just seem to happen
more and more often lately and in these
end games where the rule of thumb seems
to miraculously fail this is something
that's not really intuitive but these
players can sometimes just just find
somehow so question yes Lily I'm out
there ready to come in maybe not maybe
not let's give them a few minutes okay
you won't try to get them in here well
let's let's do it
let's do this variation all I'll try to
defend for black though I think it is
lost so let's say King g3 okay 95 mm-hmm
kingi excuse me b7 King c7 King g4 takes
here let's just say King C says maybe
there's a different let's just try that
for first though and well then I guess
King e6 immediately over so king b6
already is striking at six
let's just first go the gut move King f5
see a king c5 is the point king b6 and
the poor King is simply not very close
so well there's there's hope I guess you
could and maybe my King e6 actually
let's just say that my King e6 is maybe
not necessary and I obviously it's
always hard to get and neither that kind
of day you know blacks kind of facing
the same problem though he'd love to
make just a threat on one of the whites
pawns on the Kings side so there's like
Oh over on this one you magically did
get there in time somehow someway all
right I think will she be able to find
something here though white is cocky ooh
King g3 was played and 95 d7 was played
so we got it we got that far we guessed
that one right
and we're saying King c7 snow to move
it's played King g4 you almost have to
take the pawn but maybe there's you
could in 88 or 90 70 or 93 but 93 maybe
Thanks and then both actually it's
actually the funny thing 97 will also
stop me from coming in there night-night
reasoning to attack some puns okay yeah
so King g4 on the board actually this is
a hard decision for Elsa let's go
through that line just to make sure
because if nothing
he obviously might do any of those other
options let's just see if this was
actually drawing so
what's the super light so let's go this
way and king c5 seems natural c5
that's not so easy let's let me see if I
can do it they're not natural
yeah yeah this looks like a looks like a
tough endgame it's very thin right you
know there's not a lot of branches to
cover it but it's it's almost like
there's there's not too many options
here you kind of just have to play it
and okay so the Belcher's play 93 yeah
this looks maybe I don't know kh5 on the
board and I'm assuming night if one is
the idea with 17 minutes on the clock I
would have expected him to spend a bit
more time there but he has a simple idea
he didn't want to liquidate everything
yeah of course so let's say these three
calculated the soudons and it was
confident he could catch everything but
everything though right yeah night if
one has not yet been played one thing is
funny is I'll just say maybe this was
reflected and captured on v7 rather than
night of fun I think this makes a little
bit more sense because he might be
planning the move g4 after King g6
I don't know how much sense it makes but
well let's just put that on the board
because that seems reasonable so King b7
King g6g for so you know F for now the
point is that the H pawn can't move this
is a little bit awkward to deal with it
I think what if I yes simply simply take
taking there well then I wasn't gonna
need to take on do that yeah the one
that was hard for me to think about was
actually F takes G and then just to move
like h3 or h4 well white it's like king
g6 and white doesn't have much time he's
got to move
and we're expecting g4 and yeah does
white have any tricks F takes G I think
is the only thing to really worry about
after Knight takes I don't know if h3 or
h4 is better but that's playing for okay
now yeah my instinct is this just lost
because just yeah it's so terrible to
have the knight in this guy so far away
this pond might even get negative it's
just kind of in the way
yeah I don't I don't like this line I
don't think this can be right well if
you don't play I thought that was a nice
idea because at least it's an idea
otherwise I don't know what you're doing
let me just say on El Sean's behalf here
that one thing with this this was our
decision point right that I think he
might have been to ative Lee like I felt
just just thought the King takes be safe
as it is and it might still be lost but
it was surprising to me that black did
get back there was something amount of
resiliency who actually saw g4 get
played and I don't yeah I don't know
what else he's supposed to do it and it
takes g4 now oh yes four is an obvious
move to play four looks quite good
although maybe each you don't like h3 h3
I want I just want to take your ear f6
pawn oh no I'm not interested in the f6
ball okay
it also maybe shakes loose tonight from
a square where it cards h6 but there are
plenty of ways for white to achieve okay
you it's fair he did play h4 let's just
okay so let's bring the king in and see
what happens right mm-hmm
so it might be close actually no I don't
think it's gonna be close cuz we go h5
let's just say King d7 g7 it's fan let's
just put this King here for kicks right
we go here and the question is I need to
tag the night and then
maybe King d6 and instead of King d7 was
a little bit more accurate because then
I could come to e5 in this position okay
so no so before King d7 right yeah so
king d6 now actually what I'm gonna do
is I don't know I'm just gonna say here
check okay I'll play King e53 so let me
just say that my King g7 is in some ways
the right idea but here it's tactical
where I don't want the night to come
back with check I think that I don't
yeah I think it would surprise me if
black could survive
it's yeah II five now seems like the
wrong square after Knight f5 all right
you can do so you played nine to five
here you could have also got D seven if
you want well I'll try King e6 after a
night of five this actually will put the
position on the board so it's king d7
okay so you can get the King e6 right so
here and then 93 you know I can play
ninety five chip let's see can i play f5
year
now I wanted to play f4 and hope that I
can keep your knight at bay with my
pawns the knight of seven is forced no
this is always going to be lost because
the the poor guy has no no way what if I
play f3 I'm gonna first I'll start by
taking your pot and then I'll come back
well I don't appreciate that
where'd your knight come from so let's
let's start actually in the game yeah
yishun and this is where el Shawn's
thinking about it and he's gonna need I
would think a problem like solution to
draw this thing definitely
how about this kingi seven well it's way
too wide so that's probably not alive
kingi eight might be more resilient
after I came out of five but the problem
is okay I go here and you still can't
take let's just show this variation whoa
I can't take right after instead of King
f8 I play Knight g4 no I have h6 yeah 94
oh you do get back you do get back okay
I have to be careful why just play what
might be a great move he just played
King upset ah the classic shouldering of
the king and poor black yeah bummer so
right yeah that's much simpler I like
that a lot
and now we're still gonna be doing
something like Knight f5 III yeah let's
see so so imagine we're gonna play
Knight e3 h6 is something to maybe
consider okay let's just take it can you
hate fighting for some kind of square
but it doesn't doesn't quite look right
let's just let's try this one first
night here right yes so this looks like
Zeus long actually
a little bit it does a little bit your
Kings just wait way too close this
doesn't this has to be lost
yeah in general that's my understanding
positions anyway yeah Oh Ellis Sean I
want to revisit this briefly while we're
waiting for this so b7 King c7 King g4
he played and he had a lot of time here
and let's just see it about this
so King bee said I think this was a
better try because you know there's only
the f6 pawn to worry about and if you
can okay let me try this again so waited
King b6 and one problem I can do
actually as I say here here right yes
fine what else I want to do here and I
want to make a claim that it was close
to zooks whoa maybe that's not true but
that's the claim right I'll try my best
to pass I'll play King's c4
I'm just trying
let's just see me for 24
so here's a question King III
good let's go down this road so here
here right tell me if I do something you
don't like all rights and here you can
play Knight h3 and your you should be
drawing this I'm willing to accept this
line because it led to me getting a draw
is king f5 they're all move somehow
there's some other way to try to win
this by playing like 96 and then either
sacrificing on g5 we're playing f4 like
you're sacrificing to you that's a king
c6
and doesn't I don't it doesn't feel
right I'm so cuz already f4 doesn't win
well I've heard another rule and that's
that nights are really bad at stopping
rook pawns Kings are the right things
are good at big it gigs are really good
okay so that looks like that at the very
least there was surprising chances to
hold this thing after king c7 here so in
this position to take the pawn what
happens on Knight 96 and f4
I'm just trying to answer a similar
position to the game so but alright so
this position here the 96 well actually
let's see where King is if you wanted to
do that maybe you could play 96 here
mm-hmm yeah I think that sort of been a
better version but I was king g4 played
in the game and ghost King before was
playing the game I'm just wondering you
know this might might have been better
for wait someone or walking down about
it a little bit but you know like 93
seems like a bummer
that's right I'll be threatening knight
of one I'll play Knight takes d5
these are pretty desperate resources
though for someone who claims to have a
winning position right but that's a good
that might be a good move
so this is what he did we got an F for
mm-hmm
maybe this here here here
I think if you take them in the box at
least something
I think I agree what if I play h4
I didn't think so
but it looks like okay you can you get
to f8 Wow
okay let's in find other things by a
hair for black though so Sean's thinking
about it now this position looks much
much less promising in terms of the draw
yeah all I'm familiar with there's some
study like positions we got this without
the plan but I don't see the parm being
a big factor like I said he might even
be in the way yeah so all right well I
guess we're about to wrap it up there
and why do we do this K but before we
leave let's glance again at our final
standings and will conclude this
beautiful tournament okay all right
let's take a look at the standings in
the a group once again so there we see
once again Lee Ann Lee the tournament
champion in Group A for this summer
chess classic Jeffrey Jean on getting
second place probably stole second place
depending on David Howells result and I
should add that that game looks like a
draw between the two Englishmen however
I will say it has not been a friendly
draw these guys have been fighting how I
had a chance to repeat moves earlier and
said no let's fight little actually this
game looks mildly similar to the game we
saw with fabbi and Magnus didn't it
looks like it should easily be drawn
mostly because White's active enough to
check back to death if he needs to yeah
so a draw their leaves Jeff green stole
second and then David and and I believe
Sam Shanklin would be tied for third
place in the group a do you want to take
a look at the group east and west all
right Corey Oprah in once again
win $6,000 in the first place title in
Group B of the summer chess classic a
full point and a half ahead of his next
nearest competitors
Igor Kovalenko had the turnaround of the
tournament starting off very slow with a
couple losses
then he really fought back and won a lot
of chess games this this event Ivana's
caboose Ian also finishing on five
points and Sam Savion and Daniel
Friedman tying for fourth with four and
a half and in the C group what's going
on here
our turfs Mike sons once again first
place in the C group outstanding
tournament from him outstanding
cheston's
some pretty crazy ones as well
I definitely excited excitement from
archers ROM Akopian ending on six points
will take second place and depending on
the result in Dimitri's game here which
we're expecting Dmitri to possibly win
although it's looking maybe like maybe
not I don't know we can't really decide
on her group here no I decided here's my
question
94 check what are you playing
then I'll play Knight h6 check okay
we've finally done something mean to me
I see it's still night g4 we get a lot
of these these similar positions but my
King seems pretty close
so just to show the the tactic that
white has to avoid is he has to avoid
this thing so he needs the thing
basically to be on g6 and right even if
I'm on g6 there's this weird thing where
you still come come back and check me to
get back to f7 quick enough let's put
this on the board so in fact let's just
go back a couple moves just to see in
this position he took it seems like it
shouldn't destroy anything but we're
wondering about Knight g4 going for some
kind of repetition and this wouldn't
matter a little bit in the standings at
least if Dmitri were to win he would be
a tie for second which is you know an
excellent result for him with just a
drop that puts him in third place so a
lot of money actually on this on the
line in the C group here and as well as
maybe this I'm not sure so here
Knight of seven though you could think
about ninety eight to nine eight seven
six and King EA I'm approaching rapidly
okay going for a xugong type thing again
but I'm gonna do a zoom 77 and it's been
a long day I'm not sure what my Zook
swung skills but that's what we're
aiming for here knight c6 and actually
just to show this as an idea imagine
King e8 what I want is I want it to be
black to move here right if it's black
to move then it's probably not so hard
mm-hmm okay so something like this is
what I made me fun I shouldn't be that
difficult to do
really and how do you how do you lose
the tempo
well first maybe I don't let's let's
start from the top mm-hmm now actually
I'm and I'm really not sure exactly
within what I do it was like this is our
position oh by the way black play kingi
egg which maybe is a better try anyway
the question with King II was what about
mr. King g7 right so knight of seven
kind of almost transposes from that
position look you can also play notes
you look for oh it's it's really weird
because okay knight c6
so this is the position you aimed for
right it was one of the ones that was
really good yeah maybe 94 is his idea of
putting my further away from the Kings
lately so if King g7 nights you for
again I got the suits one with a knight
move like Knight f5
and you you know your King has to go
someone funny okay King g6 was just
playing
right and so
but wait what did what did we say before
it was Kenny a really I wanted to do
King g7 that that seemed right because
then on Knight f7 I have the knight c6
zukes one well king g6 I don't I still
want to play Knight g4 I think rather
than the original idea seven just king
e7 I don't know how you're ever going to
push h6 with the king on g7 is my only
concern
because you can push my night away for a
tempo but I think you can always get
back using some kind of check now play
Kingi 8 and just sit on it
so King it might be a bad square because
then I get checked when you promote if I
play King e6 and you play the same idea
Knight H - do I have time to come back
and capture your pawn I guess maybe I
cannot it's a major bummer with the
rip-off this is the position we've got
on the board and I believe it's now so I
wanted as I said I wanted it to be white
to move here so then we could play
knight c6 but I'm assuming that there's
going to be a way to push the night away
here yeah do I know exactly how it is
not yet but so for example the problem
is 96 here and I don't quite know how to
do it so this is our current position
you let's say Keaney 7 serious
difficulty let's say let's just pretend
that's forced one actually one
well let's see
let's see what happens here so the
position we have an ID f5 check King it
seems natural uh I never really know
when when I should play King 8 or King
e6 but I guess II eight is a bit more a
bit more natural you want to keep it on
f8 square if the white king of reliefs I
just I don't see the idea for a white I
don't know how you can achieve this kind
of an exact maybe you play King g6 after
King e8 but then there's a just like a
knight check-in in back to f7 so right
we need to lose a move basically this is
one of these end games right where
there's gonna be some losing move thing
for example right and the reason why you
have to do the lose is the move thing is
that there's always a color thing it's
either it's always white black white
black white black and in this position
for example you would very much like it
to be black smooth mm-hmm
it wore for example we imagine we put
the knight on g6 and then told black it
was his move but unfortunately that's a
quite work that way
no do I still think this is a win I
think so so Knight h4 let's just massage
a little bit and just just to get a
sense
hmm white plate night g3 maybe he has
some notion here that we're gonna sim
King g7 that was played yeah
now if you're white you go around and
you go around and you go around and try
every score on the board for the night
before you give up but it is the colour
thing and there is no weight the only
way to lose this a move would be to
somehow triangulate the king right so
one thing we could do is if he ever goes
King on a king we construct a situation
where when he goes King e6 maybe we can
do that hmm so for example let's say 94
here we see the oh it looked like the
other players in going Jones that David
how we're about to agree to something
but no they were just switching out
their notation sheets preparing for more
and more and more chess moves passing
that move 60 fun stuff that games gonna
be a draw those guys just like to play
yeah so King e6 on the board and this
might be a moment for King I don't
actually don't understand King g6 that
much here King g6 that there's just a a
95 check probably and then if anything
but King g7 then the black King can come
to f7 it does seem like what that what
was that it was a move where he played
king g6 and I want a king v7 that seems
like the move where he lost the color
the back-and-forth color maybe and if
you ever just go look at night em game
studies you'll see this white black
thing white black thing quite a bit okay
he played King g8 he's trying to lose
his move
yeah there we go King g8 and oh good I
like this so imagine Knight h6 King h7
Knight f7 King g7 we've triangulated and
got that you have but what if I just
play King e7 what then I'm gonna think
then about King h7 to come back to g7
then King f8 I don't think you can give
me this f8 squared so what if that's a
year let's say give me 7 ok I have a
silly idea so what if I come back to g7
I come back to e6 and then I play King
age 7 in that position or even maybe
better I paid like he ate in this
musician ooh
Knight s tonight h6 is my intuition but
then don't
I didn't try and get like there right so
if you're saying King g7 night of seven
did did we actually I didn't I didn't
triangulate okay wait let's go to the
game so this is our position
how about king h7 here hold on there's
some controversy in the other game Rick
f7 was just played are we sure this is a
drive why don't we take a look and see
what's going on all the way back up and
group a look up seven so there's this
threat to take on f6 right and if d7
then there's maybe a Bishop a4 chat
maybe not
well if d7 there's a rook takes f6 rook
takes f6 and then I can't I can't
calculate so let's say d7 is right and
that's the intention no the first thing
is if here here here because I'm Brooke
a2 you could just snip but what happens
on Queen no no that'd be my fear is that
black is simply checkmated well I have
no idea what's happening here
maybe this is the game we should be
looking at what do we have we have that
night at game and onions are fun but
look at how many pieces are on this okay
so this is our game position and I think
this the reason this is turning into a
struggle is they kind of want it to be
struggle they like they've been fighting
every step of the way to avoid this draw
and one player might have succeeded all
right they've both got zero time what to
do
d7 is the only it's the only way
otherwise rook takes f6 and then Queens
it's got to be g7 here d7
give me like one check the quesadilla
happened so Rick takes f6 is the
critical line I think
well I'll submissive a for right well
Bishop a4 I thought that looked drawn
King takes c5 and now there's two
questions one is Bishop takes that's the
first one so Bishop a4 check was played
and I guess this pin is actually really
really annoying I'd wonder estimated
this one Oh
Gawain you lost your 2700 rating buy
eggs eggs I think he's in big trouble
dude David Howell gain has 2700 pretty
seems possible when we pull up the live
the live ratings here see what's going
on
that's crazy David hell is gaining
exactly zero point zero rating points so
far yeah so when today would put him in
the positive but not over 2700 okay it
looks like that guess see I I guess go
away blew it there and let's look back
we had the thought that if King f8 this
would be a draw and one thing we should
say for sure is now if we lifted the
Knights off the board it would be a draw
so that's already that's already one
thing is over our our rule of thumb
holds yeah so okay it looks like there
was like one moment that
Gordievsky missed it okay well there's a
lot of a lot of tries for black to
really hold that end game and we found
ourselves wandering down this path but I
thought that like especially that King
takes b7 move earlier looks right it's
pretty strong it was surprising then he
got got away with it where and maybe we
missed something but that was hey we
have more moves played in that other
other game still going on so rook takes
Bishop a4 check King D 6 and then rook
takes f6 so kind of combining the ideas
so you got us you have to stop the pawn
Surak F 1 Bishop f5 Bishop f5 and Wow
Rick a1 is forced and then this is just
dead lost just H 5 H 4 H 3 H 2 H 1 oh ok
well let's wrap it up there that's the
end that is the end if we will take a
commercial break and I will say goodbye
I have to run off to do something I'll
say goodbye that was a beautiful
tournament thank you all so much thank
you Kip Thank You Jesse for joining me
so we're gonna take a quick break and
then I guess I'll come back to wrap
things up
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what a tournament we've had indeed they
received the final two players shaking
hands calling it a day and with that the
summer chess classic has been concluded
no more chest left to be played so let's
take a look and see where all the
players ended up in Group A once again
Liam Lee takes home $12,000 with a first
place score of six out of ten it was a
very close field in Group A with Jeffrey
Zhang and David Howell both finishing on
five and a half points just behind Liam
Lee Sam Shanklin takes home fourth place
with an even score of five out of ten
Darrow's spirits had a very respectable
tournament played very resilient chess
and very interesting chess but only came
home with fifth place at four and a half
points and golly and Jones kind of
suffered a catastrophe halfway through
and has lost quite a few games in the
latter half of the tournament bumping
him all the way down to three and a half
over in Group B if Gregorio oberon
taking home first place with an
astounding one-and-a-half point lead
over the rest of the field he takes home
$6,000 egor a couple unko once again had
the comeback of the tournament started
off slow but came back and won quite a
number of games in the latter half of
this event Nelvana Scoob Uzi and ties
Kovalenko for second place
also with five points and let's check
out Group C our turfs Mike saans takes
home sole first place in the C group it
was a rocky road for archers but he
seemed to always come out on top when
the complications arose a rhombic Obion
was his nearest competitor scoring six
points and taking home $3,000 Dmitry
Gordievsky perhaps had the best chance
of anyone to catch archers with his game
against archers yesterday it was a crazy
event and our turfs managed to draw the
game but likely missed quite a few wins
along the way al Shawn had a 5 out of 10
score an even score taking home $2,000
once again congratulations to all of our
champions this year
Liam Lee a Gregorio Pirin
archers Naik Suns your summer chest
classic winners unfortunately Liam Lee
was not able to come in for an interview
but we wish him all the best in his
future chest exploits and we hope to see
him back in st. Louis upcoming events we
actually have the grand Chester Lake in
Croatia will be going on for the next
probably week and a half or so very
exciting stuff the world's best players
all joining us in Croatia to battle it
out people like Fabiano Cara Juana and
magnus carlsen the world champion and
you can join us here on our YouTube
channel for more commentary on that
event better commentators than eyes such
as Yassir Sarah Wong yo Vanka alejandro
maurice all of these famous faces will
be giving you the best commentary
available for croatia we also have the
US Junior Championship the US girls
junior championship in the u.s. Senior
Championship coming up directly after
Croatia
starting July 10th once again it's a
exciting summer of chess here in st.
Louis well it's about time to call it
there I think so thank you so much for
joining me and joining Jessie for this
entire tournament of the summer chess
classic we had a blast giving you the
best coverage we could over these games
some astounding players some astounding
games and we will see you in the next
events
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
[Music]
you
you